So sure you can have an interpretation
what had happened could be in the Bible
itself but then there is also a higher
criteria from Allah saying even if
Muhammad's in doubt even if you're in
doubt you can go to the previous
scripture as an authority just to prove
that what I'm saying to you is true no
you misceding I mean I got the wrong
yeah I got the
passage no
because this passage didn't mention if
one of the verses
We have not sent a messenger except from
from a man. Ask people of the book.
Meaning ask the the people of the book
if Allah did not choose human being as
the messengers. That's what he mean.
Doesn't mean ask him everything because
in your book there's many prophets from
human beings. That's what I'm saying. So
he's saying if you Muhammad there's no
the verse before
it allows
What time is my class? What time?
You mean
this? You mean this?
It's the verse before. Yeah. So, so when
Allah Okay.
What is up
now? Then Allah said in so Allah
speaking about what the context clearly
that Allah go ask people of the book if
Allah did not what and we ver so the
part clear and also also I know what you
mean I know what you're going to say but
I was just understanding that but also
Allah the word the tool in sometimes
Allah use it in something will never
happen for example the Arabs they will
say if I want to show you that I'm very
famous or I'm known I'm very known I
will tell you ask the tree about me if
you are doub in doubt yes does a tree
speak I'm emphasizing to you that I'm
one no doesn't mean you act in doubt or
you should ask okay even if Muhammad is
sorry Allah is speaking in a very
rhetorical question no obviously cuz
he's not but he's saying to him even if
you ever want to decide it's going to be
there the answer's going to be there
yeah about what about the past before it
no yeah exactly is which is is there no
not just that in any scenario no it's
not in any scenario because that's why
the context is very important because
he's not asking ask them about no that's
why it's been mentioned in two places
been mentioned that the Arab pagans they
said it's very strange that Allah choose
human being as a prophets so Allah said
ask people of the book meaning people of
the book is known in the Arab peninsula
that in their books Allah have chosen
many many human beings as a prophets of
god the other one is about Allah bi is
so Allah people of the book which is ben
is knows what Allah did for them raised
them he protect them, he favored them
and everything. So he never ask
everything about because there are some
stuff which is a lie. Allah in the Quran
for example that the h the lie that they
attribute to Allah in the old testament
that Allah rested and refreshed Allah
refuted this lie. So Allah go ask them
about this because it's clear lie
against Allah. Yeah, but the question is
if like obviously the Torah for that
Allah is obviously going to it's like an
example that obviously Allah is going to
be talking to Muhammad. Muhammad has a
lot of listeners asking me questions and
one of the questions I can't get my head
around is that he's telling me Allah the
gospel the people the gospel the judge
for our books if our books are corrupted
in certain extent and then we go to
Muhammad which is the authority because
he has Allah if our books
um has an authority because there are
some truth to it like you said yeah
there's some truth accept that if the
truth is when we go back to that it's
going to be in it but The Jewish people
and the Christian can't be able to find
it. No, they do. No, no, no. There are
some Jewish people they do find Islam.
You see? No. That's what I'm saying. I'm
saying the Jews for the Torah for the
No, no, no. The Christians will some
Christian utilize the passage which is
uh paracletos paracletos. They say if
you go back and study it very well and
go back to Greek, you can pronounce it
something as Ahmed. So there is some
Christian who accepted this this name is
there. That's why I'm saying what you're
doing. You have to come out of this uh
bubble that you have that you are the
only Christians who Allah is addressing.
Not Allah address all the Christians.
Okay? And other Christians have the
scriptures which contain some truth
which you do not have. As for Allah
telling you to judge what is in the if
you read the passage which
is here is
not is not as a
commandment which means Allah gave the
to Jesus in order to rule by it at that
time. Okay. As for the other
explanation, there's a verse which Allah
said to go to to to to judge what is in
the in the Torah and the is about
prophet Muhammad wasallam being
prophesized in your scriptures which we
do find it like when you go to autonomy
is there Jeremiah is there what they
call it in Isaiah is there even the new
testament is there like passages when
Jesus said there's a lot of stuff to
tell you but I cannot tell you right now
but when I leave the comforter that's
why that's why it's a paracus the
comforter will tell you the scholars
differ who is it prophet Muhammad who is
not and they go back to the word in
Greek they said this could be Ahmed is
what if different that part I have to
disagree because no why I'm showing you
brother out of respect why I'm showing
you this topic why I'm showing you this
topic you have no leg to stand on
against Islam using this topic because
why this topic that's why I don't really
speak about this topic too much
especially for the New Testament I use
Jeremiah sorry I
is Isaiah but when you come to New
Testament I haven't did the study it
very well for a long time the last time
I studied probably like 10 years okay
but I still remember some points in the
New Testament which some Christian
scholars who accept Islam likewise
Muslim scholars who knew who knows Greek
and everything they say there's passages
which you can translate it if you go
back to to to Greek can be pronounced as
Ahmed that's what I'm saying that's a
homework for So, so just it's not like
you know that's why I would speak about
clear clear which should not bad but but
clear cut you believe something to be
God which go against your own self
intellect you go against your own
scripture why you still believe in
someone to be God which clearly it goes
against God's nature which you and I
will believe in that's the question we
should be addressing he was saying
earlier he was dressing to a specific
group of Christians at a time of Mecca
I'm sorry no Mecca the de all the time
I'm telling you that this topic like
example every Christian has like a
different view but they all come to
conclusion that Christ is God and he's a
trinity by the resurrection no no not
all there was many Christian that have
never believed Jesus to be God about
unarians yeah there is that's what I'm
saying no Christian denies Jesus
resurrection that's their belief no
there is scriptures like I told you
haven't read I read scriptures which
they believe like if you read the book
of Bartman lots of scriptures there is
scripture which is was called a gospel
of Jesus the savior or something else.
He mentioned that Jesus was never never
died. God raised him and they were
that's what I'm saying. So that came 101
1,100. That's why you claim about them
but they say we don't accept that. But
we don't it's like me saying this
respect you have to go like no but old
brown like you're saying that these
individual don't exist and they don't
believe in opposition to what you
believe but they do. No, what I'm saying
to you that you have to stop listening
you are the only Christians that exist.
I'm showing you the gospel that you have
now there many Christians don't hold it
as a gospel. Okay, they have different
gospel even even now for example. Okay,
which one is the correct one? The gospel
of the Protestant or the Catholic the
books cuz you have some books in your
Bible the the Protestant and other
Christian uh sects do not hold it as
holy. So which one is correct? Uh before
how many Bible books were there? Before
you tell me how many which one's
correct? I want to know. No, I just want
to know because Yeah. No, no. Before
which one is correct? Which one? Okay.
Now, okay. The Coptic the Coptic. You
know the answer. I'm Catholic. I'm going
to say seven. Okay. That's what I'm
saying. So that's my point. If you go to
other Christians, they say, "No, the
answer is us." Cuz we can trace it back.
If you go back to the Coptic Christians,
they're going to say, "Look, you see
that the point we Muslims, yeah, we
Muslims, we have we have sex in Islam,
but all of us, we unite. Quran is the
same Quran we had we have different
Quran even the Shia the extremist one
not even
the extremist one the extremist one they
say the Quran never been corrupted but
the one we have but is the one the pure
one is with mi yes even so we don't
differ that prophet Muhammad messenger
of Allah we don't differ that Allah is
one we don't do you differ from the
after Muhammad died there was a surah
problem how many there should be for
example Abu Bak said there should be 111
surah
never true because argument that certain
revelation he hasn't added that should
have been added. No no no no
no he believed there was two
supplication which was abregated.
However and all the Sahabah agreed
because right the Quran was revealed in
stages. There are some passages was
abrogated and some passages were what
they call it
uh we're going to use the word uh what's
the word like state okay anyway remain
that's the word remain so basically he
was trying to like continue life so so
there's some sahaba who did not hear cuz
before proam passed away the last year
of his the before he died in Ramadan jir
revised the Quran of him twice with the
last uh revision to abrogate the other
chapters that knowledge did not have and
told us clearly to follow and um and man
must is based upon the mus of omar which
habsa had it in our house that's why man
called her and he said bring the Quran
then all the other sahabah and the
sahaba agreed with the Quran he accepted
that he was wrong of course why are for
example the
of house
house recite house came through
who house
was so so you cannot use the argument
about our respect there's only one
problem that if everything was perfect
for the converation of the Quran why did
need that necessity to burn the Quran
that other Muslims have the other that's
good questions because the Quran and was
reviewed in a different way of reciting
it. Okay? Because the Arabs had
different way of speaking like the
English speakers. Now, the people of po
of Liverpool have different accent and
different ways of speaking in London.
Likewise, the people of Britain speak
differently than the people of
Australia, New Zealand. And this shows
us the Quran of different ways of
different ways of reciting Quran. and he
shows prophet Muhammad he's been sent by
God.
Last question I'll leave. Last question.
It's the same question.
Who is he talking about? The guy he
cover his face. He think his phone is
not but he's not.
Carry on. Can leave them.
You lost.
Anyway, the Quran been reviewed in seven
ways of reciting it. Just this
Why? How come I'm deficient when I hear
about this
guy Mohamad Alib who about his man?
Where is our belief? I don't know. I
always hear that when he filed and
compiled the final verse Quran, they
always talk about he had 116 suras. I
want to know where just the other two.
No, no. The two sur believed it was part
of it, but it was abregated. That's why
it got changed after no change Allah
obligated for prophet just I mean it was
later looks disciples sometimes they
know some things and they don't know. We
don't believe they know everything.
Okay. Yeah, that's why Allah taugh us to
follow the companions not just for us to
follow one companion. Okay, like for
example, if I tell you something today
and one of my disciples not here doesn't
mean if you had something the opposite
you tell no Hashem said something else.
I mean like the logic of like who to
trust and I just want to know at that
time cuz it seems like every scholar I
see from Muslim until later they just
fixed it man decided at first 16. No
verse 16 114 you get you get
he had two surah he believed he was part
of the Quran but it was abregated that's
it all the 114 wasn't for it the
greatest like no no the greatest said
they mean
greatest told us
about is better than everyone and the
Quran of man so just to understand why
he compiled the Quran do you He might
have
the other two verses. No, it's not
because why? If there's 60, imagine
there's 500 people say Shemi said he
went home and there's one person say did
not say that. Which one you going to
accept? If none of them met Muhammad,
only one say the difference. If 500
people, all of them, there's 500 people
met me. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. 499 they said
something. Yeah. One of them said no.
Shi did not say it. Which one you going
to take? Obviously the majority. So the
majority disagreed
with so so that shows me why don't hold
yourself which is doesn't have perfect
knowledge everything. So the point here
is that the Quran so why he put it all
into or he told them to burn because
some of the Sahabah had the Quran which
some verse was abregated through the
last revision had and some recitation
was as allowance for the Sahabah but the
the Muslims who came after they didn't
know that so they start different
amongst each other so so all the Sahaba
came together and agreed to keep it this
Alhamdulillah. By the way, we still have
the even the mas is burnt, but we still
have it. So, it's been saved.
Alhamdulillah. As long
even though the analogy you gave the
500, which are full, but obviously Ukman
when came along, there was a lot of war.
So, a lot of the tribes who had follow
Muhammad, they already died some
citations. So, I'm trying to understand
even though that's not true. You're
going to declare it's not true. But they
didn't a lot of Muhammad's followers
died in war. No, no, no, no. He took so
you mix it between time. No, it's just
because Abu Bakr's time he was the
reason to compare the Quran. He needed
someone to like also help him as well.
No, listen carefully cuz you mentioned
corrective knowledge. You're talking
about the time Abu Bakr when some the
scour of Quran died. Yeah. Yeah. So came
to Abu Bakr. He said this I've noticed
law of Quran died. So let us put the
Quran into break all soul into one musf.
They did it. But to show you there was
still more Quran passed
away had only one copy and they kept it
for the government for the if it was
needed they will make another copies for
the of course they were steal of Quran
the compil compilation of time the
purpose of it the other Muslims who were
learn the Quran different way of
reciting it when they met each other in
Azra Bjan they didn't know that the
Quran was different ways so was
explained to them then some Sahaba said
listen the reason Allah revealed Quran
in different ways as to make it easy for
the Muslims. We don't have to follow the
other anymore because it was just to
make it easy. So let us unite upon the
of and of the the way
of way there's other that's it agree
with it which alhamdulillah all of them
do you think Muhammad gave an easier
recitation for
Ibas easy I mean all of them have easier
he must have probably heard him to say
that these are the revelation Muhammad
told me
I don't understand your question you
said that obviously Allah So you say
like yeah obviously I can give one
recitation but not many will understand.
No no no understand it. I'll give you
example in the some some people say they
cannot say they say okay some people
they they cannot pronounce some letters.
Okay that's what I'm saying because Arab
had different ways of speaking that's
it. I mean like I respect you know
you're hanging on this is just I told
you I'm going to meet someone but you
know I will tell you look I will tell
you why the Quran still preserved if the
Jewish people now and the Christians and
the Muslims all of them decide to ban
their scriptures to get rid of the
scriptures which scripture we can bring
it back into the written
form is that even if someone can recite
it the main thing is can you understand
it? No, no, no. Change now.
Understanding. No, no. I'm asking you
now. Ask a question. Yeah. Now, if the
Jewish people, the Christians and the
Muslims, all of them get rid of the
scriptures. Yes. Which people are
allowed to bring the scriptures back
into written form. Obviously, I know you
don't say as a Muslim. No, you No. Which
one? I'm asking you. Muslims cuz why? We
memorized it. So, the same Muslim
memorize it today, they were able to do
it yesterday, last year, last century.
Same thing. That's why the Quran is
being preserved. I don't believe you.
You have to go lie. I told you there's
team summer win.